next on book TV Martin Dugard tells the
story of journalist Henry Morton
Stanley's African expedition in search
of missionary and explorer dr. David
Livingstone this public lives feature is
45 minutes and you all can hear all
right terrific well good evening and as
I said welcome to Roman's bookstore it
has been a very busy and exciting day
for us as I told you earlier we had a
Pulitzer Prize winner here at noon and
today we have with us not only a New
York Times bestselling author but a co
holder of the around the world speed
record so this is a very exciting
interesting day at Romans Martin Dugard
is our author this evening I wanted to
share with you a couple of the great
reviews that this book has been
receiving the book as you know is into
Africa the epic adventures of Stanley
and Livingstone he's received a starred
review from Kirkus and here's just a
little excerpt they called the book an
action-packed recounting of one of the
most famous incidents in a history of
exploration fine entertainment for
adventure buffs solidly researched and
fluently told also getting great reviews
from Publishers Weekly Library Journal
and one of the most critical readers we
have here on staff sherry galantine who
came in everyday to tell me how far
along the journey she had passed and how
she couldn't believe that this story she
thought she knew was so engrossing in
fact she lost a night of sleep because
of you and she was pretty mad about it
Martin
in addition to this book Martin Dugard
is the author of farther than any man
and knocked down the harrowing true
account of the yacht race turned deadly
he's also the co-author of that New York
Times bestseller that I mentioned
earlier survivor the ultimate game his
dispatches have appeared in GQ Sports
Illustrated and Esquire and we are
delighted to have him here with us this
evening will you please help me welcome
Martin Dugard to Roman's bookstore
well thanks very much it's a it's great
to be here
I've never been here before this is a
great store you know bookstores are all
shapes and sizes but this is a fantastic
store I'm gonna hold this because my
voice doesn't carry very well you know
it's an interesting point that this is
one of the stories that everybody thinks
that they know but and even as I began
writing and I thought that I knew it and
in fact it's it's a largely untold tale
there have been several biographies of
Stanley and several biographies of
Livingston and several recounting of
various African explorations during
during the the 19th century but but this
is the first time and I've checked this
out thoroughly this is the first time
that anyone has taken just the story of
Stanley Livingston that little snapshot
in history and in brought the two
together and what I thought was gonna be
every simple story you know Livingston
gets lost and he finds him he says dr.
Livingston I presume you know end of
story turned out to be this fascinating
epic you know it's it's a you've got
loved you've got you've got malaria
you've got you've got tribal warfare
you've got all these things and and it
doesn't just unfold in Africa it unfolds
in London and it unfolds in New York it
even unfolds in the American West and
characters like like Ulysses Grant and
Buffalo Cody even Buffalo Bill Cody even
made an appearance so was just one of
those things that the more I began to
dig the more it really kind of came to
life for me but I'd like to read a
little bit for you just to kind of give
you an idea and this is the part that of
the story that everybody does know but
just a brief recap and in in April 1866
dr. David Livingstone who at the time
was the world's greatest Explorer went
into Africa to find the source of the
Nile River he was he was an older man he
was definitely on the last journey of
his life but he was the world's greatest
explorer and you know and during the
Victorian era explorers were like rock
stars they were they were incredibly
famous individuals and and Livingstone
was the greatest of them all I mean he
had no parallel when he walked down the
streets of London he was mobbed when he
went to church he was mobbed he was he
was just one of the one of those people
that had this kind of this aura about
him that even people like the Duke of
Wellington who
who had this who was a very omnipotent
person respected and it was attracted to
was drawn to and even the Arabs who who
whose slave trade he Livington battles
so vehemently were drawn to him as well
they said he had something called Baraka
which was this aura of spiritual
spirituality and greatness about him
that drew people to him but he goes in
Africa he gets lost he is missing for
five full years and nobody knows where
he is the greatest Explorer in the world
is just gone it's as if he has vanished
off the face of the earth and reports
filter back out of Africa that he has
been eaten by cannibals that he has been
burned alive that he has been been
hacked up by a rogue zulu band called
the mazda2 and even that he's taken up
with an african woman who started a
brand new family all these rumors come
out of it but but nobody actually goes
in to check and that is left to a young
American reporter named Henry Morton
Stanley Stanley was actually Welsh who
had taken on in American persona and
adopted everything American and
convinced even his employer James Gordon
Bennett jr. of the New York Herald that
he was actually an American he had
fought for the blue and the greater in
the Civil War which kind of helped his
cause and he was just this young upstart
reporter who was desperate to prove that
he could do whatever it took to keep his
job and at the time the newspaper Wars
were very huge in New York and in London
so being a top newspaper reporter was
was just as important in Stanley's
profession as being the top Explorer was
to livingstone profession but let me
read a little bit to you just to kind of
give you an idea of it to set the steam
to set the scene Stanley is marching
into moojiji
which is the village on the shores of
Lake Tanganyika where he has heard the
Livingstone is waiting and again no one
has seen Livingstone since since April
1866 by now it's November 10th 1871 the
view from the summit took Stanley's
breath away
for the first time Lake Tanganyika shown
below him it was like a silver sea
bordered by the most amazingly ominous
mountains Stanley couldn't take his eyes
off of it even as the caravan descended
the mountains far far aside it had been
almost exactly two years since Bennett's
Commission the pressures and risks of
marching across Africa to find
Livingstone had been on his mind every
day since somewhere down there
the shores of that sparkling Lake lay
you GG to finally see the spot where the
meeting would take place and a lovely
spot it was a beautiful reward for all
the toils and struggle was like a dream
come true as the miles passed the
caravans trail wound through a field of
ten foot tall metate a grass elephant
grass that obscured their view of the
lake but did nothing to slow their pace
in a few minutes stanley wrote we shall
have reached the spot where we imagined
the objects of our search our fate will
soon be decided no one in the town knows
we are coming with a caravan was just a
mile outside of town stanley order the
colors raised and men to begin
renouncing their arrival he gave the
order for every man to load his guns
commence firing he roared growing more
nervous by the minute that he was on the
verge of meeting the great Livingston
what would happen with the veteran
Explorer run in the other direction
would he be warm was there a possibility
as Kirk had predicted that he knew of
their coming and had already left you GT
the flags are fluttered Stanley wrote
the banner of America is in front waving
joyfully the sound of muskets firing in
horns blowing fills the air punctuating
the flags presence never were the Stars
and Stripes so beautiful in my mind the
residents of the town soon came pouring
out to greet them the arrival and
departure of caravans was a regular fact
of life in OGG but there had been none
for months due to the war with mur ombo
stanley had blazed a new trail for the
caravans to travel she was no longer a
journalist writing about the actions of
others henry morton stanley had become
an explorer with all the incumbent fame
and glory that implied even as stanley
strode into town surprise and happiness
could be seen on the faces of the arabs
and locals alike the arabs pressed
against him shaking his hand and asking
where he'd come from they were much
astounded to find it to be a caravan
Stanley wrote and to be led by a white
man the whole time Stanley anxiously
surveyed this the faces around him but
there was none but the time Stanley made
it to the heart of town thousands of
people were pressed around the caravan
and though it was a triumphant moment
with all the fanfare Stanley's
phenomenal achievement deserved
he grew suddenly impatient Livingstone
was nowhere to be seen a young black man
that appeared at Stanley side and spoke
to him in English how do you do sir
hello
who the deuce are you I love that line
who the deuce er is cracks me up I am
the servant of dr. Livingstone he was to
me and as soon as he uttered those
intriguing lines he dashed off just as
quickly as he had appeared joy Stanley
wrote in his journal heart beat fast I
had to keep control over my emotions
lest my face might betray them or
detract from the dignity of a white man
appearing under such circumstances but
what would I have given for a bit of
friendly wilderness were and I might
vent my join some mad freaks such as
idiotic Lee biting my hand twirling a
somersault slashing at trees or
something in order to purge these
exciting feelings before appearing in
the presence of Livingstone everything
had come together for Stanley finally
his years of hunger and failure and
rejection his desperate underdogs need
to succeed at all cost his desire for a
loving father figure Stanley had waited
a lifetime for a moment of such
appreciation and validation now that had
come the world spun off-kilter robbing
him of the stern and angry facade that
had driven him across Africa in his
place was a humble young man desperate
to do and say the right thing when
meeting one of the world's greatest and
most famous men he wanted to appear
smart in Ghent Ile devoid of any
pandering tone in his voice minutes
earlier Livingstone was sitting on the
mud verandah of his small house
pondering his woeful future his seat was
a straw mat with a goat skin on top for
cushioning behind his back as he leaned
against the Hutt's mud wall another
ghost skin was nailed the skin kept him
from getting a chill as he leaned
against the cold mud suddenly he
witnessed the unusual sight of little
Suzy racing down the dirt street when my
spirits were at their lowest ebb the
Good Samaritan was close at hand for one
morning Suzy came running at the top of
his speed and gasped out an Englishman I
see him and off he darted to meet him
Livingstone slowly rose his doorway
faced East the direction from which the
caravan was marching Livingstone could
see everything clearly above the throngs
of people gathered to greet the incoming
Caravan he saw the American flags
snapping in the breeze he didn't see a
white man but porters bearing an
incredible assortment of goods soon made
themselves obvious they carried bales of
cloths huge kettles cooking pots tents
this must be a luxurious traveller
some thought and not one at wit's end
like me with Livingston Sol was at and
gaunt young man whose hair was per turn
prematurely white the stress his uniform
was as crisp as could be expected given
the travel his boots were well-worn his
son beaten helmet had been cleaned all
in all the man has such a formal bearing
that despite the Stars and Stripes
Livingstone assumed he was French he
hoped the traveller spoke English
because Livingstone didn't speak French
he thought that they would be quote a
pretty pair of white men a new GG if
neither spoke the other man's language
what Stanley saw was a pale white man
wearing a Sun faded blue cap in a red
jello jacket like the Arabs his clothing
showed signs of being patched and
repaired the Explorers hair was white he
had a few teeth and his beard was bushy
he walked with a firm but heavy tread as
if stepping on thorns Stanley stepped
crisply toward the old man removed his
helmet and extended his hand not
counting the months between his Great
Commission in the start of his journey
Stanley had come 975 miles and 236 days
for the moment they wordlessly shook
hands each man appraising the other
livings didn't know did not know who the
young man was or what he might want the
Arabs and citizens of vgg crowded around
according to standards
according to Stanley's journal it was
November 10th 1870 done 1871 a day that
would change the world
Stanley's heart was beating furiously
and he was driving desperately to say
exactly the right thing to such a
distinguished gentleman
Livingston's British background though
gave Stanley great pause he wasn't sure
whether or not he was welcome how
Livingstone would react or whether he
was about to be embarrassed in front of
a large throng but Stanley had not come
across Africa to be denied with formal
intonation representing America instead
of his native Britain but trying to
quote but trying to affect British
gravity and trying to quiet that
singsong Welsh flutter the crept in when
he got excited Stanley spoke the most
dignified words that came to mind dr.
Livingstone I presume yes
Livingstone answered simply he was very
relieved that the man was not French I
thank God dr. Stanley said appalled at
how fragile Livingstone looked I have
been permitted to see you I feel
thankful Livingstone said
I'm here to welcome you and and that's
kind of the summation it's and I like to
think of that as the moment the book
that every it's like reading a book
about a storm that's the part everybody
knows you know about the storm and here
you know about the what's going on and I
haven't given anything away that what
what Kate what comes before and after is
just as much the surprise is just that
little moment there and and like I said
the more I dug into this the more I was
fascinated by the the nuance and the
subtleties and just the intricacies of
it and as I don't know if any of you
were listen to KPCC this morning I was I
talked a little bit about when I
researched this book I actually I felt
it necessary to actually go to Africa to
to follow in Stanley's footsteps to see
what it was like to to just experience
some of that same stuff and I expected
it to be vastly different than it had
been and what I found instead is once
you left the cities of Dar es Salaam or
or Tabora or even OGG Africa is largely
unchanged Africa is still this vast
empty wilderness just grassland and
acacia trees and in lions and leopards
and hyenas and it is and it's amazing to
me more than ever
how Stanley was able to march across
Africa as this relative newcomer to
Africa and to do so successfully when
when when Britain's best explorers have
had either been unwilling or unable to
do the same thing and another another
incident when I was in Africa kind of
brought all that home to me I was I to
of our friends came along with me almost
at each one was a stockbroker and you
know we were just it was it was the
summer it was August of 2001 and we had
hired a driver in Dar es Salaam and he
spoke Swahili and we were following the
path exactly we got to to a certain
point and it was five o'clock in the
morning we were about to begin pressing
our journey you know further inland
we're almost halfway to Tabora and the
driver had received word from some
friends that there were bandits on the
road ahead
and he suggested that we detour kind of
a little bit southwest it was a better
Road we could we could make good time we
would actually be able to follow some of
Livingston's paths and then we could
backtrack later and you know do the
Stanley thing so that was great I said
you know that's fine
and it was it's kind of a real surreal
morning because the the guesthouse where
we hit
stayed was just this it was this small
lodge right in the middle of the
Savannah and it was just a real Loeb mud
house with with with a thatched roof and
in the in the restaurant area the night
before I had I had left the table
halfway through dinner to use to use the
men's room which was down a long hallway
from from the dining area and as I was
walking down this hallway I had the
strangest feeling that the walls were
moving and I didn't realize it but it
was a it wasn't just a guest house it
was also herpetology exhibit so as you
walked down the walls these glass
thousands of snakes black mambas puff
adders cobras everything everything in
Africa is in these these cases along the
Wallace and I'm walking through there
and it's it's dark and and it's you know
it's it's Africa you know when I'm alone
and I'm thinking this and you know and
then the black mambas herb they're
really these speedy snakes and one of
them was climbing the glass up and he
couldn't find a way out but I'm thinking
yes the glass is that thin yeah well
he's got to do is get lucky and I'm just
cooked and so that's kind of stuff
that's on my mind you know so we get up
the next morning and we we get in our
vehicle and then the drivers taking this
new course and it was a beautiful
morning and it was that it was still
dark and they there was this full moon
rising over the mountains as we kind of
descended up and we ascended up into the
mountains and you know the moon was just
this bright husky yellow and you know
just followed us everywhere it went and
we could see a river down in the valley
below and it was just really mesmerizing
and then all of a sudden it at one point
there was a there was an overturned
truck just a big big cattle truck in a
mile later there were just a whole herd
of cattle running down the middle of
this of this dirt road just just
charging and I felt so bad for him
because they're literally charging to
their deaths because the minute they
stopped to rest their lion food and I
felt so bad for my wanted to tell me go
back go back but I guess they're dead
either way right so they they they were
just running and so this is it's the
surreal thing we got the moon we got the
cows and we had the snakes and we kept
going and then the Sun came up and we
got to this little village of 10 Duma
which is on the Zambian Tanzanian border
and like anywhere in the world like like
in Tijuana like in anywhere the border
towns are kind of a rabid manic place
everyone
kind of ng they want to get across the
border and they got someplace to be and
they can't get there cuz someone
stopping them and in Africa a lot
especially because you don't have really
paved roads in most places people will
congregate in the roads aren't too many
cars and when a car comes along they'll
part and then they'll come back together
you know and then they just go about
their business well as we came through
the crowd parted and we weren't going
very fast but at the last minute a
pedestrian darted across the road and
our driver couldn't stop soon enough and
actually hit the pedestrian and with the
left front bumper and I was watching and
this person just literally sailed and it
was just this horrific sight we stopped
the car and we're opening the door to
get out and none of the crowd cared
about the person no one's going to help
the person all they wanted to do was
pull us out of the car and kill us and
all this of miraculously they've got
clubs and they and they you know they're
they're pummeling in the back of the car
and they're trying to rip us out of the
car and so the driver just floors that
we're slamming the doors and we're
getting out of there so the question is
what we do we're in Tanzania we don't
know the rules there are some countries
in the third world that will just throw
you in jail for something like that
until a trial can be held that could be
months or years or whatever and we're
then what are we going to do so we're
driving across Africa and you know fifty
miles an hour on these these rutted dirt
roads and dust flying and literally
passing elephants and and giraffes so
again we've got this surreal quality to
all that's going on and we're fearing
for our lives and we decide that in the
next town when we finally get there
we're just going to go to the police and
tell what happened and just take our
chances
so five hours later we finally get to
the next town we don't need to go see
him they're waiting for us they've got a
roadblock out there they've got
automatic weapons and it's one of those
things too that when they talk they
don't keep the weapon pointed this guy
they keep a pointed right at you as they
talk you know randomly just kind of
waving it around and so they get in the
car and I got a guy here and my buddy's
got a guy on this side of him we're in
the back seat and there's a guy crowding
into the front seat as well they take us
to the local police station and the
first thing the driver does is a tell
them in Swahili that he'd actually been
asleep in the back even tired that I was
driving I was the driver and that you
know and that I should be thrown in jail
so they do they put us in jail and we're
trying to explain ourselves and
interrogators name is Mohamad and first
question he asks us is our is what is
your religion and then he says what is
your tribe and I'm thinking it there's
not a right answer here you know I don't
know what I'm gonna say how we're gonna
get at this so we just figured we would
tell him the truth and we would just
hope things came together and it was it
was then it was one of those weird
insights as a writer that you you kind
of get what you what you asked for
yeah I had come to Africa to find out
about Stanley's journey I but I didn't
know what I was going to get was a real
slice of the kind of the stuff Stanley
went through on a daily basis this this
getting up in the morning thinking it's
a beautiful day looking forward to this
great adventure and halfway through your
day something happens that just rocks
your world and you're you're totally cut
off from the rest of the world there was
no telephone we could use there was no
telephone Stanley could use if we had
simply disappeared there no one would
have known what had happened to us we
were we are out there and I'm not saying
that our journey was even remotely like
what Stanley went through but Alice and
I had a sensation of the kind of fear
that he must have had to to to squelch
every single day you just have to you
know shove it down and just kind of
trust have some kind of blind faith that
everything's gonna work itself out and
it doesn't always but in this case as
with Stanley's journey as with us it did
work out and they let us go and I'll
never forget at the the police
commissioner of the town was this it was
a matriarchal kind of town it was this
enormous woman and she was a picking her
nose with two fingers I've never seen
them before both nostrils and she gives
us our freedom well thinking this is so
weird you know just let us go you know
and so they give us the car back the
driver actually stays behind and it was
kind of a funny coat it was by the time
we got back to Dar es Salaam somebody
had paid somebody he was we saw him
walking on the street outside our hotel
and he'd been there for two days he beat
us back to Dar es Salaam by a long way
but we continued on and in and again it
what it did was it that part of the
journey not only took us into the realm
of the unknown but it broke up the pace
of the journey so we no longer
controlled it
we didn't our schedule was was shot it
all of a sudden we were just kind of at
the whim of whatever Africa wanted to do
with us and by the time we finally made
it to Gigi almost a week later we had
gone through a number of other strange
and collab
little adventures including it at one
moment getting on the train and in the
middle night it made a stop and all the
prisoners from the place we had just
been we're thrown on the train that had
been stripped naked they had manacles in
their hands and their feet they were
literally throw in a board like sacks of
flour and they were just in the
passenger compartment on the ground and
people are stepping over them to get to
the dining car I kept thinking that
could have been me you know it was just
weird
it was just odd and so when we finally
got to Gigi and the place where Stanley
and Livingstone met it's it's not what
you think it's gonna be you think it's
gonna be this marvelous obelisk or
something like that it's a it's a very
nondescript Monument almost in someone's
backyard and surrounded by a fence and I
had to bribe the guy to let us in and I
think he everybody has to bribe the guy
to let you know it's one of those things
but when we finally got there I kind of
felt like I'm sure Stanley felt like who
we know we did it we we achieved this
thing because it what a start off with a
very simple journey had become this this
Grail you know this quest that we had to
we had to fulfill and a number of times
we were thinking yeah you know we don't
really need to see that spot we can just
get on the plane and you know there's a
plane leaving tomorrow we can get on
that plane you know but we can't have to
keep going and that was that was a
really neat thing it was kind of a
another way to illustrate how hell off
the the the world the rest of world
Africa still is when I was in moojiji we
decided that we were gonna take the
train all the way back to civilization
I went to the train station I tried to
pay for it with a credit card you know I
don't know what I was thinking but I
gave the man a credit card and he turned
it over in his hands kept looking at it
you know he didn't want to appear stupid
but finally he said where's the money
yeah I said there is no way yeah it's a
magic you know I couldn't explain it but
but but you know that was kind of the
essence of the whole research and what I
did when I began writing the book was I
took those experiences I took I took the
smells of Africa and that kind of that
underlying fear that Africa gives you
and you were when you're there and it's
one thing to do it a kind of one of
those game safaris where you're
shepherded around us nothing to to kind
of all the sudden find yourself just
just cut off out there and it was there
is this underlying feeling that you
really got it you're gonna watch your
back
and so I took all that and plus the
beautiful sights of Africa of the acacia
trees and and just a lion in the while
just seeing a lion sunning itself and
then but just that that kind of that
Menace about it and in just you know
going by streams and seeing just these
these pink stepping stones across the
surface of the streams and looking
closely and realizing those were all
hippos backs and it was so cool you know
you look at that I think this those are
hippos you know and it's not Disneyland
you know those are real hippos and you
know night and I began writing and I
began making a number of trips to London
to the Royal Geographical society's
archives and that even brought it made
it more immediate because I as I read
Stanley's original journals in living
since journals and the journals of other
people who were prominent in this story
it was it it was so much more immediate
because when you see things in someone's
handwriting I mean their actual own hand
you hold their letter in their hand and
you see a drop of blood that has fallen
onto the page as they wrote it you know
probably under a piece of mosquito
netting
near a campfire 130 years ago it just it
just makes these these two-dimensional
historic figures that everybody thinks
they know it Stanley and Livingstone
they're almost cartoons but but all of a
sudden they kind of rise up off the page
there there are these these these these
people they're kind of alive you know
they they take on you know their
thoughts you know you know you know how
they speak you know how that you know
the way they write you know how it is
when you read someone's letters you can
kind of tell something about him by
their handwriting you can infer that and
it got to the point that as I as I wrote
the book in my office at home they were
it was like they were looking over my
shoulder
and I know that sounds strange but they
were very very much alive to me and now
as I I kind of put close the door on
them and get ready to write another book
I almost feel as if I'm betraying them
in some way like because there are these
they're these people who become such a
part of my life they're there it's
almost like there's some kind of
relationship was a very one-way
relationship but they have they have
told their story to me through Africa
through their words and their letters
and and I kind of put it on the page in
a way that I tried to write it not as a
history book because I think history
books are boring and they put me to
sleep and I love history but it's just
dull like that but there's you know I
try to write it like a novel like a
fast-paced narrative you know cram all
the detail in there cram all the
information cram every bit of
in there and don't embellish anything
but tell the story in a way that that
makes you want to turn the page because
that's what their adventure was like it
just didn't stop and hopefully I've
accomplished that and that was my goal
the whole thing is to tell the story in
a way that makes you want to go from
start to finish and hopefully not put it
down anyway
thank you very much for coming out if
anybody has any questions I'd be happy
to answer them yes sir
where did you get access to the letters
of Stanley and Livingstone there's a lot
of places it's this is a fun book
because it's like detective work the
letters are all in various museums and
archives around the world now the
British Library British Museum Royal
Geographical Society Archives the
Scottish library the New York Public
Library well everybody has a little bit
of everything the world look at
geographical society has the most of the
stuff and as you can right bless you as
you can imagine it is um you know these
are the people who sponsor Livingston's
expedition and you would think that they
would have everything digitized and be
this high-class thing you know basically
you go to their headquarters and you go
up to the attic and they give you this
big file box and you're going with and
someone just stuff the stuff in there
and you you pull it out and and there is
the invitation to living since funeral
and there's um there's a picture of
Stanley that that he had just kind of
signed and tossed aside it's all this
it's like going through someone's you
know someone's attic it's really cool
but another thing too was um was that
was the great age of newspapers so I was
able to go to the British newspaper
library and they've gotten they've got
newspapers from around the world for
centuries and actually look at what the
Times of London was saying with the New
York Herald was saying with that with
the Bombay papers and the Cape Town
papers were saying and you know the fun
thing about that was not just the that
kind of you know just the verbatim stuff
about Stanley Livingston it also tells
you things like what the weather was
like so it's as a writer that's a great
thing you can say on this day it was
raining it was 52 degrees that's a great
thing you know because then you don't
have then you can really set the scene
as opposed to just kind of alluding to
you know you think London it was you
know say say it was cloudy and kind of
hope it was cloudy this week it you can
be
specific so that was great yes ma'am oh
I got the microphone how long were you
gathering your research you know I it
was like it was an ongoing process I I
spent four months before I began writing
doing research reading reading other
people's biographies of those
individuals reading about the era going
to Africa for three weeks and then
making a preliminary trip to the Royal
Geographical Society in the British
Library and then as is with anything the
more you know the less you know and so
just when I thought I was done I did
find some nude no I got to go back and I
got to do this and there was this for
instance there was I thought the book
was done and there's this one character
in the book sir Roderick Murchison who
literally is the architect of the
British Empire he is one of the most
underrated unknown people in history and
without a doubt he he deserves much more
stature than he has been given by
history and there was a point in the
story where his wife dies and because
his wife is dead he throws all his
efforts into getting Livingstone home
because Livingstone is really his only
friend he wants his friend back and he
and he just devotes the rest of his life
to that moment but to really tell the
story accurately I had to know when his
wife died but for some reason if you
look through the London papers that time
and everything there was no obituary
there was no notice of her death or
anything and I kind of tried to bluff
and finally my editor said you got to go
back you got to find the tombstone and
you got to know when she died and so I
did I made this trip to London just for
just to go to Brompton Cemetery and look
at her tombstone but again
what happens is I look at the tombstone
I realized it's made of a certain kind
of marble that was found in another
monument that's predominant in the book
and everything kind of starts going off
on a new track so it's fine
you know and at some point I just had to
stop and I just had to say it's done yes
sir at the time we were writing this
wasn't Lake Tanganyika and Victoria even
the source of the Nile pretty
well-documented I had never heard that
Stevenson Livingstone was actually lost
at that time what happened was in 1857
sir richard francis burton and John
Hanning Speke went in to find the source
at first they thought the source was
like Tania
and then they thought this and then
speak went north and he'd said thesaurus
was Lake Victoria and they came back to
London and they're going to have a
debate about what the source truly was
and the papers were calling it the Nile
duel because you know the Nile at the
time was mankind's elect greatest
unknown geographical mystery it was a
huge thing to find the source of the
Nile it was just major and so 2,000
people packed into a conference room in
bath and I think train remember the date
off the top of my head anyways a cold
rainy day mm people cramped in there
they've been waiting three hours in the
rain just to get inside they're wet
they're angry they're hungry and 11
o'clock comes and goes Burton is there
speak it turns out has killed himself
and so he can't present his side of the
story
and so what that with the Royal
Geographical Society says they take
Livingstone who had just been totally
shamed by his previous expedition and
who needed to make sure he had enough
money for his retirement and to do that
he needed to be able to find the source
and write the definitive book about that
search the Royal Geographical Society
went to Livingstone and said you will be
the one to find the source of the Nile
go and find him and basically they're
thought to be a piece of cake they
thought would take him two years at the
most
and Livingstone and then Livingstone
basically said don't you know you need
to make sure you pay me this you know
we're gonna and he got that he got the
agreement and off he went and then he
disappeared yeah actually they didn't
pinpoint the exact source the Nile until
the until in 1960s with satellite
photography in nineteen in the 1930s
they found a north and a South you know
lakes in the mountains of Burundi that
were kind of going into Lake Victoria
but it wasn't until 1960 so they
actually pinpointed the source no no
what you gotta read the book or this
it's about the book all right it's about
the book your work you're working this
thing okay okay now he wasn't he wasn't
lost he was just overdue yes ma'am
how did you choose this topic to write
on I wish it was more profound I've got
a beautiful wife and I have three lovely
sons but I also have a great deal of
wonder
and one of the things about my career is
that I get to I guess travel a bit and
the more you travel the the more you
kind of narrow down the places you
really want to go and as an author you
the books you get to write about next or
the places you get to travel to write so
I wanted to go see a lion in the wild it
was that simple I had been to Africa
before but I'd never seen a lion so I
knew that I wanted to go back to Africa
to see a lion it really began with that
but then I just written about Captain
Cook and I knew I wanted to write about
explorers as well so I needed to make
that link between the nautical
exploration in the 18th century and the
the more land-based exploration in the
19th century and there's a link there
I'm not gonna bore you with the details
but basically Sir Joseph Banks who
sailed with Cooke formed what later
became the Royal Geographical Society
and so there's this huge you know
continuum in exploration and when I
settled on this thing see now here
here's where the symbolism comes in this
is what I love Livingstone it turns out
that this came up in the research was
known as the Lion of Africa so I had my
lion and I saw two in the wild so that
was cool
yes man I guess I want to know what your
next topic is yeah I can say this now I
just we just made the deal a couple days
ago I'm proud to say this it's about
Christopher Columbus's final voyage his
fourth voyage and it's not the usual
columbus book because his last voyage
was this epic debacle he all of his
ships sunk
there's gold there's sword fights
there's there's warfare it's there's a
Shackleton type thing where one of us
men goes off in an open boat to try to
rescue them there's treachery and it's
it's just a very humbling experience for
Columbus and I found though when I began
to research at the Columbus is not what
we know he never had his picture ever
painted or drawn in his life so any
picture you've ever seen in Columbus he
is not what you think he was six and a
half feet tall he was freckle-faced he
was red-haired and a fair skinned and
when I read that I just kind of flipped
everything around I thought that's what
I want to do I wanna I want to write a
new portrait of Columbus in a way that
people have never seen him before and
what he did there he did many very
unexcusable things but he oh he was also
a very brave bold man
and I want to balance those two in this
portrait and it's gonna be tougher than
this because the research is not so easy
to find so that's gonna be fun yes ma'am
with all the adventures that you had in
Africa you're gonna write a book about
that part of it your own you don't want
to drink you know it's hard you know
that the book world tough him is yeah if
nothing else it's always still a
business you got to write books that
people want to buy and and I want to
write about those travels but I also
feel like there's still a little bit too
close I want to put more distance
between them to write about them well
you know Hemingway once said that you
need to be able to you know put that
distance between you before you can
write about something that's what I want
to do I want to write about that and
somebody wanted write about all these
adventures you know what I want to write
about the trip around the world which it
by the way was is not as epic as it
sounds we were in the conquered and it
was a Sports Illustrated assignment we
flew it mock to at 60,000 feet eating
filet mignon drinking champagne for 31
hours but I got the record all right so
it's you know that's but it'd be fun
it'd be fun to write that stuff but I
just want to do it well I don't want to
do just a you know kind of a half-assed
job I want to do it in a way that really
brings it to life yes ma'am
when I heard you talking on the mantle
show today I sort of thought about a
book I read it the called heart of
darkness did you get a that sort of a
sense of the Africa that you were in
parts of and and do you think or did you
find anything that that indicated that
the exploration might have been for more
than just to find the source of the Nile
that's a good question and actually it's
true you know Livingstone did have an
ulterior motive
because he had when he his previous
expedition of the Zambezi was to open a
waterway into the heart of Africa so
they could call it as Africa and the
idea was but you know it was a very
Victorian point of view that if you gave
the African people the ability to to
farm
go cotton the ability to have commerce
come and go and they were control the
flow of Commerce and then eventually he
will also want to have Christianity and
colonialism as part of that that you
know that that grew up there that
bracket
he thought he could he could you know
propel Africa into the next century into
modern times and so when he when he
failed on the next edition of the
Zambezi and part of the reason obviously
is Victoria policy you can only go so
far up the Zambezi you can't go into the
heart of Africa he wasn't he never
really stopped searching for that path
but now it's interesting you know Joseph
Conrad based heart of darkness on
Stanley Livingston and yeah he did he
did yeah Livingstone was this curtsy and
figure and and and he really admired
Livingstone a great deal he loathed
Stanley matter of fact when Stanley was
returning from this journey chronic
Connor I was living in Marseille at the
time as Stanley came through and Conrad
my facts may be wrong in this but I'm
trying to think about my research he
tried to commit suicide shortly
thereafter there was something about
that whole thing that really he despised
that brought him down so yeah it's it's
the Victorian era nothing ever there's
ten different things going on there
layers upon layers and layers and stuff
like that
oh no no we got subtext no uh yeah I
think I did my job I think I did my job
there are a lot of layers like I said I
was amazed that well you know here's
here's a point I make in the book and I
and it's open to historical debate but
is the same time all this is going on in
Africa the exploration of Africa the
opening of Africa the exact same thing
was going on in America we had just as
Livingston's pushing into Africa we had
men pushing across America the
difference is we had one country that
eventually settled all of America so we
we kept kind of a cohesive you know sent
sense of unity
whereas Africa became fragmented you had
all these different nations you know
making it a little bit of piecemeal this
and that and and I just my point of view
I think that's why Africa has never
always been different and that's why the
tribal differences are still a strong
now as they were when Livingstone was
there yeah any males have any questions
Oh what is the attitude towards Stanley
Livingston today in Africa if anybody
cares oh sorry what is the attitude
towards Stanley Livingston today in
Africa if anybody cares it's they're
kind of bemused you know it not too many
tourists make the trek to places like
Tabora to see Stanley's this house
Stanley rented for a while or not 20
tourists actually go to ugt to see the
the place where they met but a number do
and those that do the locals kind of
look at him like you came here why yeah
but they know they know why you're there
and I got off the train I in in Tabora
and I and the cab drivers out front you
know makes us on like this big you know
yellow cab or one of the big London cabs
it's a it's a little Toyota with the
doors off and and the gather the seats
were smoke of getting soaked of gasoline
and it just you know and we're driving
over these ruts there's this deep and
the cars bottoming out but he took me
out to Stan Lee's old house but he knew
immediately upon seeing me that that's
where I wanted to go he figured it was
only reason I could have come and yeah
it's it's it's like anything else it's a
tourist industry what I have Stan Lee's
Journal you
ooh the original yes now after I shot
you I just wanted to shock you I was
gonna say years ago when I was doing
publicity at 20th Century Fox you saw
the movie Stanley Livingston with the
special agency movie yeah well
throughout the picture of Spencer Tracy
writes in a journal and I was on a set
one day and I saw that journal I said to
the property man that's from Stanley
Livingston he said sure I said that
really interested me he said if you want
it you can have it oh my gosh so I still
have it it's really weather-beaten it
looks like something that Stanley would
have written and it has been Tracy's
handwriting in it so Wow that is
something I'm humbled that's really cool
I can't have it all right I'll give you
a book give you a free buck and an audio
cassette okay you know as when I was
researching this there was this you know
the British Library if you if you look
up documents they won't let you look at
some of them if somebody has actually
purchased that recently they have a law
that people can actually buy British
documents but they before they're taken
out of the country they're put on
microfilm and and then the person who
purchased it purchased it usually at
Christie's or South piece can request it
no one is allowed to research it use it
for research for a period of up to five
years and there was this one document
the Livingstone had written a letter to
actually to Sir Richard Francis Burton
after the Nile duel explaining why he
was an explorer and I really wanted that
document and it turns out was owned by a
judge in Washington DC Russell train who
is a the chairman emeritus of the World
Wildlife Fund and I just called him and
he transcribed it for me and then very
often he said oh by the way I just
bought Livingston's gun at auction it's
like man you know that it's gotta be a
lot of money yes so he knows cool - I'm
kind of going on here but last just last
summer just not even a year ago in an
attic in in just outside London some of
stanley's relatives found boxes full of
Stan Lee's original artifacts that have
been sitting there for a hundred years
they found his compass they found his
his his copy of Burton's lake regions of
Central Africa dog-eared and in a
written in the margins so he yes he
planned for this journey and
all that stuff you know they found his
gun they found his pistol everything was
just someone found at the Attic so it's
history huh anyway thank you all very
much for coming out I'm gonna hang
around sign books and if you do get a
chance to read the book hope you enjoy
it very much
thanks again Martin Dugard is author of
farther than any man and knocked down
his latest into Africa is published by
doubleday on the web at double date com
next week on public lives gentlemen
revolutionary Richard Brook